so the first thing we're going to do is
we're gonna draw some graph so I don't
care what it looks like let's try it
put a few vertices here and some edges
connect it up nicely okay so there's a
graph and now I'm gonna give each vertex
of my graph a number and again you can
just choose this randomly and it can
even be a negative number okay so let's
say I've got negative two here I don't
know what do you want here right three
and one
and how about minus one and I don't know
another two so here's the rules of the
game the goal is to make sure that none
of the vertices have negative numbers
anymore okay so you can think of this
this one name for this game is $1 game
which is that you can imagine this as
five people and they have this amount of
money some of them are in debt some of
them are not and the moves that you can
make in the game are that either a
person can donate money meaning for each
vertex that they're connected to they
can give a dollar or a person can take
money meaning for each vertex that
they're connected to they can take a
dollar and the goal of the game is to
make sure that everyone's out of debt
and no peeking or choosing if you give
or take you have to give or take from
everyone you're connected to that's
right that's right
so let's take a look at this example
that we've drawn here and see if we can
win this game so what do you think we
should do well I think three person has
to give good ok so let's do that let me
do a different color so we don't get
confused okay so if 3 goes that means 3
goes down to 0 mmm
2 goes up to 3 1 goes up to 2 but here's
something good which is that this is now
negative 1 instead of negative 2 which
is better for getting everyone out of
debt now what should we do that three
needs should give a cross written yeah
we've got all these extra money over
here and so why don't we move some of it
do you want to move all of it we could
just do three consecutive moves moving
money over yeah yeah that's right it's
ok to be on there you just don't want
any debt so let's do three moves each
time we'll donate $1 from this vertex to
it's only connected guy ok
great so now we have two problem
vertices left these two minus ones so
what should we try why don't we
consolidate oh let's try it so you want
to donate oh sorry you went the other
way
well if this donates usually you have to
give two there oh you're donating the
other way oh sorry I see what you're
saying this no let's do what you said so
this thing donates to everyone so it
goes from being minus one to being minus
four right yeah okay
now this person can give to their good
good yeah let's get rid of his three
okay so five can give goes down to two
one two minus two and then I guess every
time we have something here we should
move it back right yeah I go zero and
three and now to up here yeah do another
good good zero minus one for oh it looks
pretty good that's right okay so one one
and zero okay oh and I went up here okay
so we went right after much much
difficulty we've got zero and one zero
one and one is we have demonstrated very
well here it's not obvious if we took
the optimal strategy to win this game
it's possible that we could have done
fewer moves and so one question you
could ask is if you hand me a game like
this if you draw the graph and you
assign the numbers how few moves can you
win the game in but before you even ask
that question you might wonder when is
it possible to win this game right like
if we had started with all negative
numbers then obviously it's impossible
because no matter what we try it's not
going to finish the problem or even you
can think about if we had started with
numbers that have the property that they
don't add up to something non-negative
right like if the sum of all of the
numbers was negative there has to be
enough money on the board to get
everyone out of debt exactly so there
are obviously some constraints for when
you can win this game
so let's do a slightly simpler version
so let's say we just have two vertices
and we'll connect them by an edge now my
question is what kind of money can I put
into this game to make it possible to
win so for example if I have -2 here
let's say what numbers will work over
here to make it a winnable game and the
answer as well as long as I have 2 over
here then I can win so in this game so
the only thing we need to win is to have
enough money in other words we've got to
have a non-negative sum in the bank on
the board okay so let's do something
similar here now with 3 vertices and now
it's not so obvious exactly if this is
still true right I mean so let's say I
have something negative over here and
maybe I don't know negative over here
again I want to have enough money on the
board so I've got to have at least 3
here let's say I have 4 or something
like that then what I can do is I can
donate all of the money from the
positive vertex to the other 2 vertices
but because of the way that they're
connected I can always balance it
between the two of them so that it works
and so the thing that was true for the
two vertex example is also true for this
3 vertex example but let's try a
different arrangement of three vertices
it turns out that it's possible in this
arrangement to have enough money on the
board but never win the game and I'm
going to show you a way that that can
happen so if I assign the number 0 here
1 here and minus 1 here then let's think
about what's going to happen so I have
enough money on the board right the sum
is 0 but if I donate from one of the
positive vertices it will immediately
turn negative and that's true no matter
how many times I try and do it and so I
can never get rid of the fact that we
have some negative vertex in this graph
even though there's enough money on the
board because you always have to move
yeah that's right because there's too
much connection right what's the
difference between these two graphs it's
that I can't move sort of freely between
two chosen vertices I have to donate all
or nothing in the second case and so
it's not enough so this is a bad
configuration
at game not winnable it's not enough
just to have enough money on the board
for all possible graphs and so then okay
the question is can I tell and it turns
out to be really complicated actually to
answer this question so I definitely
advise that you sort of mess around with
this a little bit you can draw any kind
of graph you want probably you want it
to be connected because that makes the
game a little bit more interesting and
assign some numbers respecting this idea
that okay you've got to have enough
money on the board right and see what
kind of things you end up with yeah you
really could I mean it depends on your
patience level but next time you're
bored in at an airport which is
something I am very often it that's
something that you can do is play this
game do you want to know the answer
Brady yeah yeah okay so the full answer
is actually really complicated but let
me tell you a partial answer I can at
least tell you that a game is definitely
winnable in certain cases so there's a
special number you can assign to a graph
call this genus so the genus of a graph
the number of edges of the graph minus
the number of vertices of the graph plus
one okay very simple to count so let's
check what the genus is in each of these
cases so in this case the genus is let's
see we've got one edge and we've got two
vertices and we add 1 so the genus is
zero in this case we've got two edges
three vertices and we add one and again
we get zero in this case we've got three
edges three vertices plus 1 so the genus
is one and so this is giving me a way to
detect this notion that I mentioned
earlier it being it's a little too
connected right it's too complicated to
try and move money around the graph and
this number which is the genus gives you
an idea of how much complication there
is and so it turns out that you can show
that a graph must be winnable there is
some way to win this game
if the amount of money you have is at
least as large as the genus of the graph
that's your surplus that's your surplus
so here we knew that the game was
winnable exactly when we have zero or
more dollars on the board
we know the game is winnable by what I
just said if the number of dollars on
the board is larger than the genus which
is zero and same here right because the
graph has genus 0 as long as there's at
least a zero dollars on the board we can
win the game yeah that's right but I
could have had a three here and it would
have worked out right and then here in
this bad game example it didn't work to
just have zero dollars on the board but
here's the reason why which is that the
genus is one and so in order to win the
game you've got to have at least one
dollar on the board
now the thing that's kind of funny is
that it's actually not an absolute
characterization of when you can win the
game sometimes you might have less money
than you think you need but you can
still win the game and actually trying
to figure out exactly some nice
characterization of when you can win the
game is pretty complicated but even to
show even to prove that this is true
that if you have as much money as the
genus of the graph you can win requires
some really advanced graph theory and so
I would be really interested to see I
don't think I've given you homework
before I would be really interested to
see a much more straightforward argument
that this is true that that having this
much money guarantees you a winning set
of moves to win the game what was the
genius of our first game and how much
money was on the oh that's a good
question let's figure it out so let's
see we've got one two three four five
edges we've got five vertices and we add
1 so the genus and this was one also and
what did we start with we started with
six minus three we started with three
dollars on the board so we really sort
of rigged the game for ourselves we
should have been able to do better
probably say you could have taken two
dollars off the board and we still would
have been able to still with it which is
weird if you go back and look at this it
looks a little difficult doesn't it yeah
but so that's the guarantees as long as
you draw yourself solitaire graph which
has this property there's always a way
to win
even if it takes you a long time to find
it I think that is the most interesting
thing is that winnable but I also think
it's incredibly interesting on what the
minimal number of moves is yeah so even
i mentioned that is it winnable is
complicated to prove I don't think that
we have a proof or a complete
characterization of what the optimal
strategy is for the
game if you like puzzles and games like
the one you've just seen why don't you
check out today's show sponsor brilliant
this is a website full of quizzes and
courses loads of elegantly designed
content this is stuff that's not only
fun to do but it's specially designed to
sort of change the way you think get you
thinking outside the box
now there's loads of mathematical
content but I think you might also like
this one I'm quite excited by it
artificial neural networks really get
your brain around how all this
artificial intelligence stuffs working
there's loads of free content on
brilliant but you can get 20% off their
premium subscription which opens the
door to everything by going to brilliant
org slash numberphile there's the URL on
the screen
our thanks to brilliant for supporting
this episode